okay the new Democratic Congress has
been sworn in Democrats controlled the
House Nancy Pelosi is Speaker of the
House and we're already seeing
Republicans triggered by Democratic
ideas and today we're going to dig deep
into first-term congresswoman alexandria
acasio courts has this idea it's not yet
a proposal just an idea of a 70 percent
top marginal tax rate on the super
wealthy specifically to take that money
and fund programs that are included in
including I guess I would say the green
New Deal which we've been hearing about
and there is so much to talk about here
and there are kind of three layers to
this thing okay first of all what's the
proposal how much tax on who and to pay
for what that's part one secondly what
historical data do we have about what
happens when you stick these high
marginal tax rates on the very wealthy
and then number three this is the most
fun part do Republicans not understand
how marginal tax rates work or are they
deliberately lying in order to confuse
people about them so stick with me until
the end because that's a sort of key
part of this entire thing so last night
in an interview with 60 minutes
Alexandria Castillo Cortez suggested
that maybe we should be looking at a top
marginal tax rate of around seventy
percent used to fund the green New Deal
and other proposals other programs and
to get rid of fossil fuel within 12
years very ambitious goal I'm not gonna
play the clip from CBS because they've
been extra aggressive lately with what I
believe is fair use of their clips but I
don't want to put our YouTube channel at
risk so we are just going to read to you
a little bit about what she said about
the 70 percent top marginal tax rate in
her interview with Anderson Cooper quote
what is the problem with trying to push
our technological capacities to the
farthest extent possible there's an
element where yeah people are going to
have to start paying their fair share in
taxes I think that it only has ever been
radicals that have changed this country
yeah if that's what radical means call
me a radical so of course this
is a top marginal tax rate meaning that
you would see a progressively higher tax
as income goes up the right like to say
when it comes to sort of understanding
the underlying philosophies of taxation
the right likes to say that taxes should
be low on the rich because they create
jobs because the rich having more money
trickles down to the lower economy and
it raises all boats like a rising tide
this is called effectively supply-side
economics the left and people who
understand reality quite frankly
understand that there is a diminishing
marginal utility to dollars what that
means is if you have ten dollars to your
name an additional ten dollars doubles
your net worth that's huge if you have a
hundred dollars to your name an
additional ten dollars is useful but
it's not as useful to you as to the
person who only has ten dollars to begin
with if you have a million dollars ten
dollars is nothing right it's interest
on a savings account it's a rounding
error it's nothing and in the same way
the more money you have the more likely
you are to just let any extra money that
you obtain sit in a savings account
which is not stimulative to the economy
as much as giving the money to poorer
people would be who would be more likely
to spend the money and inject it into
the economy this is called demand side
economics at a certain point the
marginal utility of another dollar is
zero if you're Bill Gates or Warren
Buffett or Mark Zuckerberg and you have
billions of dollars a one percentage
point increase in your taxes which
leaves you with one percentage point
less money at the end of the year it has
zero impact on your life maybe it's not
literally zero but it's Oh point zero
zero zero zero zero one percent of each
dollar actually impacts your life and
your financial decisions in any way that
is what a higher top marginal tax rate
capitalizes on that for the very rich
those additional dollars do nothing for
them but they would do a lot for other
people for the
for social programs etc so now that we
understand the idea let's look at the
data about the history of these very
high or higher top marginal tax rates
the u.s. used to have more tax brackets
and they used to have higher tax
brackets at the top so under Dwight D
Eisenhower as president the top tax
bracket was 91% this went down to 50%
under Reagan this went down to 38% after
the 1986 tax reform with more tax
brackets you can have different top
marginal tax rates for someone earning
five hundred thousand dollars a year a
million dollars a year ten million a
hundred million right now everybody
earning over five hundred and ten or so
thousand dollars a year pays thirty
seven percent okay that's it the highest
bracket starts at five hundred and ten
thousand dollars in income and there's
nothing else above that it's thirty
seven percent all the way up so then we
get to what this policy and economic
research tell us the top marginal tax
rate should be well the question is what
are you trying to achieve the right is
correct when they say if you keep
raising that top tax rate at a certain
point it will stop people from working
at all
which the government doesn't want
because then they make zero right so if
you go to high it actually reduces
government revenue what MIT research has
found is that a top marginal tax rate of
seventy three percent is the point at
which the government will maximize
revenue by taking advantage of that very
high-end for whom those additional
dollars have very little utility there's
complex math around it which we don't
need to get into but the point is a top
marginal tax rate of 70 percent as sort
of floated by alexandria castillo cortez
if you set it up with the correct
brackets would be something that raises
a ton of money for programs that would
actually improve our society so that is
the the sort of history of the tax
brackets now lastly some republicans
seemed
not understand that this is just a
marginal tax rate it's not the rate
anybody pays on all their income so as
an example Republican Congressman Steve
Scalise tweeted over the weekend about
Alexandria Acacio Cortez's interview
with 60 minutes where she talked about
this he said Republicans let Americans
keep more of their own hard-earned money
Democrats take away 70% of your income
and give it to leftist fantasy programs
no one wants to take seventy percent of
your money based on a 70 percent top
marginal tax rate okay everybody pays
the same rate on the first five hundred
and ten thousand dollars that they earn
you then put in place higher rates for
money earned beyond that now I don't
know if Steve Scalise and other
Republicans who are saying this stuff I
don't know if they don't understand how
marginal tax rates work or if they're
deliberately playing dumb to incite
their followers but let's explain it
really really simply okay I put together
the 2019 actual tax brackets
with some hypothetical higher tax
brackets that would get us up to 70
percent marginal tax okay so in reality
right now everybody pays 10 percent on
income up to ninety seven hundred
dollars everybody doesn't matter if you
made a million or ten million on your
first ninety seven hundred dollars you
pay 10% likewise you have rates of
twelve twenty to twenty four thirty to
thirty five and thirty seven percent on
other income ranges so if you make a
hundred thousand dollars a year you pay
twenty two percent on everything between
forty and eighty five thousand and then
for what you earn between it's exactly
80 for 201 and a hundred thousand you
pay twenty four percent on your first
eighty four thousand dollars in income
you pay the same as everybody who makes
less than you and everybody who makes
more than you so the way that you could
set up a tax bracket system the way
Alexandria Castillo Cortez is proposing
is that maybe you pay thirty seven
on income between 500 and 10,000 and a
million dollars and then for income
between one and ten million you pay 45%
for income between 10 and 50 million you
pay 58 percent and then you pay 70
percent tax only on your income above 50
million dollars a year so if you earn 12
million dollars you pay that 58 percent
rate only on what you make between 10
and 12 million dollars again this is
this is hypothetical this is how
marginal tax rates work this is kind of
like debt and deficit I can't believe
we're having this conversation and that
I have to explain to people that the way
the right is talking about this stuff is
either ignorant or I guess we would say
deliberately ignorant in order to
mislead you the idea that someone is
going to swoop in and say you now give
me 70 percent of all your income that's
not how marginal tax brackets work my
question to you do they know this and
they're playing dumb in order to fire up
their followers to say aoc wants to take
all your money or do they not understand
how marginal tax rates work send me your
thoughts send me your thoughts on our
Instagram page well we will be posting a
clip from this show david pakman show on
instagram follow me David Pakman quick
break back after this